the
lord of the rings trilogy yeah has a
pg-13 rating in the united states
that means
that in each
of the movies you can have one swear
word where would you put that swear word
are you really yeah
for instance
in the fellowship of the ring i could
say
[ __ ] buckle berry ferry follow me
and you could get it past the census but
wouldn't that be brilliant
so we're i want to ask people at home
where is the best place in each movie
because gandalf could go [ __ ] full of
attack
or before like when i know my skeleton i
could go oh i'm really [ __ ] sorry
oh god that's really the gift that keeps
on giving right
in the mind
they have a [ __ ] cave
or the best one that i've thought about
to now
in um
returning the king and sending your
suggestions if you have any but [ __ ]
aragon my friends you [ __ ] bout to
know
so send in your suggestions yeah where
would you put the swear
[Music]
words with me and hold me back all
through
you're shining bright i'm your boy's the
baby you're my
[Music]